Chile has the working girl blues she's
tired of being caged up like a canary
and decides to go out on a lock forgive
me mother if I stay out after 9 o'clock
who wouldn't forgive or take a look
at that outfit an old-time nightclub
where bad people drank good liquor ah the
fleets in another red hot number Oh lady
be good you recognize the Playboy it's Mack
Sennett come on slip skirt let's go on a tear
is this place wild I asked you back home
mother is praying that Chile doesn't lose
her equilibrium easy Tilly she's afraid of the
boogeyman and here comes Oscar with a new idea
in making now Tilly prepare to make your big
mistake oh the shame of it take that you and
come with me says ma'am I'm just in time
to save you from a fate worse than death
down at the old glue works where the boss
is stuck on Tilly the employer Auto zilch
is being played by Arthur Johnson one of
the early screen lovers it was a case of
love at first sight he should have taken
a second look he invited her for a stroll
don't they make a romantic looking couple
the clothes are by special permission of
the copyright owners well if it ain't Oscar the
kiss burglar the big love scene which shows you
why some call it madness Oscar is fluffy
will her name be mud or will it be zilch
the happy bride
silly acts as though she's been married before
does anyone know why this couple should not be
joined in holy matrimony old everything
shouts Oscar she's no longer a good woman
I kissed her this being an old picture Tilly
now gets historic oh boy next week Eastland
Oscar is telling how he threw the static into
the big church hookup who's that behind him
listening in wives Minnie the moocher come
with me loud speaker I'm going to cut down
your volume wait there's new evidence choi min
min now show him up Oscar admits Tilly made no
big mistake it was just a social errand
kiss aunt Agatha din has a last request
the mourners will please file out quietly
bin was a shoemakers daughter so she gave
them for all chilly chilly you gorgeous
creature at last you are going to be a